buckle up kids Taylor Swift is talking
about her past and present beef with
Kanye West and it is one wild ride in a
new interview with Rolling Stone
magazine Taylor breaks down the
decade-long Feud like literally
everything and yes that includes Kanye's
song famous which reignited some serious
bad blood between them in 2016
bad blood get it anywho
after years of publicly fighting and
making up Taylor tells the mad quote I
realized he is so two-faced
oh damn them fighting words of course
the drama all started ten years ago with
this moment Taylor I'm really happy for
you i'ma let you finish yeah that was
Kanye interrupting Taylor's acceptance
speech for Best Female Video at the 2009
VMAs shutting down her victory hard but
Beyonce had one of the best videos of
all time oh it's so awkward like a
decade later and it still gives me hives
I was standing on stage and I was really
excited because I had just won the award
and then I was really excited because
Kanye West was on the stage then I
wasn't so excited anymore after that
Kanye quickly apologized but years later
he said that he didn't quote have one
regret about the situation and he said
his apologies were a result of quote
pure pressure that shouldn't even
categorize with the greatest living
artist that we have to date to even be
put in the same category so that apology
yeah we'll just call it a wash but
things seem to be friendly between
Taylor and Kanye rumors even swirled
that the two might collaborate I think
we've talked about it but we've also
talked about so many other things
Taylor revealed to Rolling Stone the one
thing she wanted after all that drama
quote when someone doesn't respect you
so loudly and says you literally don't
deserve to be here I just so badly
wanted that respect from him
I hate that about myself Taylor
explained that they would go to dinner
and Kanye would say nice things about
her music and she felt like some healing
had taken place so when the 2015 VMAs
rolled around they decided to publicly
end their feud once and for all
on stage as Kanye collected at the
vanguard award according to Taylor
Kanye specifically requested her to do
it
he can be so sweet he can be the
sweetest and I was so stoked that he
asked me that well Taylor wrote a sweet
little speech that went something like
this
I am honored to present the 2015
Vanguard Award to my friend Kanye West
but Kanye said well he said this you
know how many times they announced
Taylor was gonna give me the award
because it got him more ratings Taylor
told the mag quote I realized he is so
two-faced that he wants to be nice to me
behind the scenes but then he wants to
look cool get up in front of everyone
and talk [ __ ] and I was so upset the
fallout was quick with the now-infamous
phone call between Taylor and Kanye
about his track famous I feel like me
and Taylor my steel head Wow I made that
famous a little refresher Kanye claimed
he got the lyric approved by Taylor
Taylor denied it even after Kanye's wife
Kim Kardashian shared an audio recording
that seemed to back up his claim the
camera crew filmed him speaking to
Taylor and got their whole conversation
I think she got freaked out by the
reaction and all of a sudden she flipped
Taylor says at first she was touched
that he would tell her about the line in
the song ahead of time but when she
actually heard the song she was not
having it quote I was like I'm done with
this if you want to be on bad terms
let's be on bad terms but just be real
about it the world didn't understand the
context and the events that led up to it
some events took place to cause me to be
pissed off when he called me a [ __ ]
and before she told the mag she didn't
want to talk about it anymore because it
gets her worked up she said quote
basically I got really sick of the
dynamic between he and I and that wasn't
just based on what happened on that
phone call and with that song it was
kind of a chain reaction of things oh
man
this anyone else feel like they need to
brace for impact like I feel a storm
coming and it's name is Kanye or Kim and
I'm scared of course you can count on us
to keep you in a loop on all the drama
so make sure to stay locked on et until
next time I'm Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]